[Musique]
bienvenue dans afrique connect nous
sommes à montpellier ville hôte le 8
octobre du nouveau sommet afrique france
et aussi d'un contre sommet dont
l'objectif est de dénoncer les maux de
la françafrique la continuité de la
politique française sur le continent
africain dans divers domaines que ce
soit économique monétaire avec la
réforme du franc cfa par exemple
regarder
loin des caméras des médias et des beaux
discours on ne peut pas avoir une france
qui construit son propre roman national
comme on dit si elle n'assume pas sa
part d'africanité se dérouler un autre
sommet le 8 octobre dernier à
montpellier organisée par une dizaine
d'associations le contre-sommet été
rythmée par plusieurs conférences
rassemblements et manifestations dans le
but de pointer du doigt la continuité de
la françafrique de sa politique
migratoire à l'ingérence dans
l'assassinât de thomas sankara si le
procès de ces assassins présumés s'est
ouvert hier à ouagadougou le mystère
persiste autour de l'ancien président du
burkina faso arrivé au pouvoir après un
coup d'état alors qu'il n'a que 33 ans
celui qu'on appelle le che guevara
africain s'est érigé en véritable icône
panafricaine tout au long de son mandat
et bien au delà l'interdiction de
l'excision l'abandon du nom coloniale de
haute-volta pour désigner le burkina
faso ou encore un taux de scolarisation
multiplié par trois en un an compte
parmi ses faits d'armes fervent
anti-impérialiste le père de la
révolution burkinabè entretient des
relations tendues avec la france en 86
alors qu'il reçoit françois mitterrand à
ouagadougou sankara remplace le
traditionnel discours de bienvenue par
une diatribe enflammée reprochant à la
france son néo colonialisme et son
amitié avec le régime d'apartheid sud
africain un an après sankara est
assassiné par un commando blaise
compaore son ancien bras droit et
successeur actuellement en exil en côte
d'ivoire en serait l'instigateur si la
france est soupçonnée d'ingérence dans
ce dossier c'est parce qu'en octobre 87
elle a fait détruire des écoutes
téléphoniques entre compaore et jean
pierre palm ex officier de gendarmerie
gênant pour le gouvernement français
thomas sankara aurait-il été victime
d'un complot international
ouvert hier à ouagadougou le procès
historique de son assassinat permettra
de lever le voile sur 34 ans
d'incertitude
a dit ce fan vous participez donc à ce
contre sommet ici à montpellier sur
plusieurs jours animé par un collectif
d'associations dont celle de notre
invité la campagne internationale
justice pour thomas sankara thomas
sankara l'ex président du burkina faso
et père de la révolution burkinabè
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
c'est moi merci beaucoup alors
l'ouverture ce 11 octobre du procès de
l'assassinât de thomas sankara 34 ans
après les faits est ce que c'est un
soulagement
oui c'est bien sûr un soulagement
surtout que vous savez ça fait quand
même 25 ans que notre campagne essayent
d'obtenir la vérité la justice dans
cette affaire donc ça a été un processus
extrêmement laborieux fastidieux nous
avons épuisé tous les recours
judiciaires à l'époque du régime
compaore nous sommes ensuite allés aux
nations unies on a obtenu des droits
pour la veuve à partir de 2004 jusqu'à
2006 ensuite on a rétropédalé le régime
s'est accroché finalement grâce aux
grandes mobilisations
il y a eu donc l'exil forcé
l'exfiltration si on peut dire de blaise
compaoré
en côte d'ivoire et là nouveau régime a
préparé ce processus judiciaire et juge
d'instruction a inculpé une vingtaine de
personnes dans ce meurtre
principalement des gens qui viennent du
pays mais nous avons la conviction que
c'est quelque chose qui est loin d'être
un petit complot local c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui a une dimension
internationale
bien sûr c'est un soulagement pour ma
part je n'irai pas à ouagadougou un
signe de protestation puisque justement
le chef de l'état burkinabè blaise
compaoré n'y sera pas dans le box et
comme c'est un élément par contumace il
c'est pas une cabriole c'est vraiment
une sorte de serre moi que j'avais fait
que je n'irais que lorsqu'il sera dans
le box des accusés
thomas sankara on va quand même
expliquer ce qu'il représente 1 il est
considéré comme le che guevara africain
d'un point de vue international il est
arrivé au pouvoir par un coup d'état en
1983 elle a été tuée à 37 ans le 15
octobre 1987 avec 12,2 est proche c'est
lors d'une réunion à ouagadougou la
capitale du burkina faso pourquoi est ce
que il est considéré comme une icône du
panafricanisme un symbole de la lutte
anticoloniale probablement parce qu'il
s'agit de la dernière révolution
africaine effectivement il a changé la
porte de production en l'espace
pratiquement de trois ans il a établi
des grands changements au niveau du
développement du pays par exemple
changements sur la condition féminine
atteindre l'autosuffisance alimentaire
des très grands progrès au niveau des
infrastructures et des besoins
essentiels et une politique
internacionalista c à vous est ce la
question palestinienne
en fait la lutte contre l'apartheid et
c'est donc il est arrivé dans un moment
où les pays africains étaient sous
ajustement structurel il a lutté contre
la dette et donc il s'est vraiment
démarqué à un moment où c'était le mode
néocoloniale de croissance qui était un
épuisement et son style à d'étonner par
sa jeunesse à sa vigueur et son
intégrité c'est quelqu'un qui a pas
toucher aux déniers publics et qui a
vraiment montré l'exemple donc la
jeunesse africaine même qui ne l'a pas
connu redécouvre à la faveur évidemment
des mobilisations que cette icône est
resté presque intacte fauché par
l'impérialisme au moment où vraiment il
commençait à moissonner les les grands
événements de cette récolte
révolutionnaire pourquoi la sphère de
son assassinat est resté aussi longtemps
taboue pourquoi autant de mystères et
autant de mystère parce que à l'instar
des types d'assassinât où il ya une
saveur néocolonial c'est très suspect et
donc beaucoup de choses semblent
indiquer qu'il y avait un complot dans
lequel étaient des agents de la cia et
les gens du liberia des gens de la
france ont soutenu le processus qui a
permis à blaise compaore de d'arriver au
pouvoir et de dit rester et ensuite avec
les forts évidemment de camoufler les
éléments d'injustice et là c'est toutes
les arguties comment la magistrature a
été manipulé mais aussi surtout comment
l'édifice de la françafrique s'est mise
en place comment les firmes
multinationales obtenu la réflexion des
codes miniers ce qui donne accès aux
ressources aurifères du pays mais aussi
dans toute la sous-région la façon par
laquelle le dispositif de la
globalisation va faire basculer les pays
africains dans l'accumulation par
expropriation et donc évidemment ce
mystère il n'est pas pour rien c'est que
il est venu empêcher que le processus de
sous développement qui était en train de
se propager donc c'est pour ça que ce
mystère cette opacité père dieu parce
que ces types de régime que nous nous
appelons comprend d'or tam est à une
mondialisation prédatrice de continuer
le procès qui se déroule à ouagadougou
est ce que vous êtes confiant la vérité
la justice vont enfin vos enfants éclaté
en tout cas c'est un immense progrès et
coûté à l'époque nous nous étions en
lutte pour obtenir la justice contre un
état partie là c'est maintenant l'état
qui instruit la faire donc on voit déjà
un grand progrès maintenant c'est sûr
qu'il ya toutes sortes de conciliabules
d'arrière-cour le régime n'est pas bien
assis il y a le terrorisme dans la
sous-région qui a été lentement
instrumentalisé par ceux là même qui ont
fuit on sait qu'à l'époque certains de
ces terroristes était un connivence ou
en tout cas en bonne intelligence avec
le régime en place qui met un peu en
otage le pays et donc ça ça pèse un peu
sur l'ambiance du tribunal mais j'espère
que nous allons avoir un jugement sain
et qu'on va aller petit à petit vers
l'élaboration la vérité auprès dix mille
pages d'instruction
la veuve e mariam sankara s'est
courageusement interposé
c'est une des rares fois qu'une des
veuves africaine des pasionaria des
femmes dirigeantes a osé porter plainte
donc faut la saluer son courage et sa
pugnacité mais là aussi tout un peuple
qui est derrière et qui attend pour
qu'enfin on ait une réconciliation
nationale et à cela j'ajoute le nombre
de martyrs africains qui
dans l'exemple symbole vont primer être
ressuscitée d'une certaine façon avec
une victoire dans ce procès parce que
vous le dites c'est une affaire qui
l'une des clés de la réconciliation
nationale au burkina faso oui j'en doute
pas moi je pense qu'une bonne partie de
la jeunesse mais aussi des gens
attendent que cette chose là soit tourné
pour qu'on puisse vraiment commencer un
autre processus un peu comme on l'a vu
en afrique du sud lorsque des icônes
sont arrêtés faucher sacré ce syndrome
mais nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
qu' il n'y ait plus ce cycle d'impunité
qui perdure et à ce moment-là peut-être
ça va donner aussi le la à d'autres
sociétés environnantes pour savoir qu'on
ne va pas aller vers cette forme
d'extrémité qu'on peut faire les choses
démocratiquement avoir du changement
social est un progrès social sans avoir
assassiné les leaders qui porte ses
exigences alors vous avez évoqué
évidemment l'absence de l'ex président
burkinabè blaise compaoré exilé en côte
d'ivoire thomas sankara c'était son bras
droit
ce dernier ne sera pas présent au procès
justement comment est ce que vous pouvez
l'expliquer ça écoutez on peut le voir
d'un pur d'un point de vue strictement
humain c'est à dire une forme de lâcheté
c'est abel et karine céder deux amis
très proches bon il a pas eu le courage
historique d'assumer le meurtre ensuite
il a caché ce qu'on appelle un anglais
smoking gun donc tout ce qui pourrait
compromettre son régime et en celui là
sans arrêt a toujours nié à tout
responsable
et à ce moment là ministre de la justice
il est au moment de l'assassinât
ministre la justice ce sont des hommes
qui quitte sa maison qui permettent les
faits certains mêmes disent qu'il est
lui-même sur les lieux en tout cas donc
tout ça doit être élucidée mais il a eu
quand même une très longue période
jusqu'à la période de prescription c'est
à dix pendant plus de neuf ans il n'a
rien dit sur cette affaire et c'est là
que la veuve a porté plainte avant la
prescription décennale et ensuite il a
instrumentalisé la justice pour cacher
la faire et aujourd'hui il passe
l'entremise de ses avocats il utilise
sur ce tour de d'arguties pour dire
qu'il n'ya pas comparaître devant son
peuple en disant que cette justice est
instrumentalisée politique et qu'on lui
fait un procès donc là il a une chance
historique de démontrer qu'il n'est pas
lâcher qu'il pourrait enfin se présenter
devant son peuple et fait exonérer du
toute responsabilité si c'est le cas
mais évidemment pour moi j'ai pas de
surprise qu'il ne le fera pas puisque
c'est une sorte de constance dans le
processus mais le fait qu'il a été
parrainé pas des gens puissants des gens
qui se prennent pour les maîtres du
monde peut-être lui a donné une forme
d'arrogance en pensant qu'il est
intouchable sont peu plus à montrer donc
son peuple a vomi il a fui et
aujourd'hui il pense à revenir par une
sorte de porte dérobée et mettre dans la
balance le fait qu'il va pouvoir régler
le problème du terrorisme problème de la
réconciliation
faut dire qu'à l'époque il faisait un
peu le sage de service pour c'est bien
votre évêque qui protège blaise compaore
qu'est ce qui empêche son extradition
vers le burkina faso très facile parce
que bon vous savez peut-être comme moi
que ces mises en place tout un
dispositif impérialiste dans la sous
région à partir
ducasse de la libye
l'implosion de la zone de ce qu'on peut
appeler le ca et listant il ya une
instrumentalisation du conflit avec que
j'explique dans mon film africom go home
qui montrent en fait à la fois le rôle
des états unis dans le redéploiement des
intérêts américains pour gelé éviter que
la chine ne soit un acteur majeur mais a
aussi le fait que on à l'accès aux
ressources immédiates les ressources des
terres rares l'or l'uranium et c'est
donc un enjeu colossal et lui n'est
qu'un élément de ce maillon puisque
c'est lui qui permettait la poursuite du
modèle néocolonial de croissance dans la
zone c'est lui qui fait et défait il
équilibre côte d'ivoire et que ça donc
c'est quelqu'un de très important
soutenu par évidemment une nébuleuse x
et que l'héritage d'un système issu de
la françafrique qui le protège
exactement et ce système s'est acoquiné
avec les éléments de l'impérialisme
lorsque ça faisait leur affaire donc
effectivement les éléments de l'africom
et états uniens était avec certains des
éléments de la politique française qui
ne faut pas confondre la françafrique
n'est qu'un appendice de la politique
française vous avez des antennes au quai
d'orsay à matignon à l'elysée vous avez
des antennes strictement affairistes
vous avez des antennes dans les cercles
franc maçonnerie vous avez des antennes
typiquement africaine qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la france mais qui eux sont
des éléments de perfusion en
aller-retour avec avec la france donc ce
sont ces systèmes qui ont vieilli
parfois très mal vie qui sont plus ou
moins sénile et qui n'en finissent pas
de mourir donc ces systèmes sont en
plein changement et nous osons espérer
que on va enfin tourner cette page mais
pour ça il faudrait qu'on ait des signes
constructif
à l'instar de notre affaire qui montrent
qu'on va aller en rupture on connaît la
proximité de blaise compaore avec 1
le président ivoirien alassane ouattara
le burkina faso et la côte d'ivoire qui
sont deux pays voisins en afrique de
l'ouest là dessus que ce qu'on pouvait
nous dire écoutez historiquement vous
savez nos sociétés sahélienne sont
parfois issus du même rameau donc la
côte d'ivoire et la haute volta étaient
deux pays voisins mais en fait deux pays
qui ont selon lui des lignes de
frontières qui ont bougé et donc en
réalité on peut être aussi voit rien que
burkinabè donc historiquement c'est ce
sont les mêmes peuples qui ont été
fractionnés par la colonisation et
aujourd'hui du fait que son épouse est
ivoirienne du fait qu'il peut se
prévaloir de ça pour pouvoir obtenir
cette nationalité qui empêche quand l'ex
trad évidemment montre qu'il ya une
connivence mais la connivence elle est
beaucoup plus tôt que ça c'est
effectivement grâce
au régime de comparer que celui de
alassane ouattara a vraiment le vent en
poupe dans la lutte contre le régime de
laurent gbagbo laurent gbagbo donc il
lui doit beaucoup de choses dans ce
qu'on appelait la guerre civile
ivoirienne la déstabilisation et son
arrivée au pouvoir et comme je
l'expliqué dans la réflexion des codes
miniers dans la sous région donc c'est
donnant-donnant aujourd'hui même si le
président ouattara prétend que c'est
juste la nationalité qui l'empêchent de
l'extrader il y a vraiment une plus
grande connivence entre eux mais
personne n'est dupe que ces liens sont
beaucoup plus profond hélas on va
marquer une courte pause si vous voulez
bien et on se retrouve pour poursuivre
cet entretien avec vous ici à
montpellier restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans un instant dans afrique
honnête
retour dans à free connect nous sommes
avec asie selbonne fall le coordinateur
de la campagne internationale
international justice pour thomas
sankara
du côté en tout cas de blaise compaore
on affirme que justifie l'absence en
pointant justement un procès politique à
son encontre
à écouter le procès il est éminemment
politique puisque de toutes les façons
dès le début ils ont refusé eux-mêmes
ont instrumentalisé pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de procès ils n'ont jamais fait la
lumière eux-mêmes en politiser la faire
dès le début en évitant que le droit
soit dit maintenant qu'aujourd'hui il
vienne nous dire parce qu'ils ne sont
plus aux commandes que le procès est
politique c'est quand même tout à fait
extraordinaire est paradoxal je pense
que ce système juridique en place on a
intérêt à voir ce qu'il mette ses
preuves à l'appui ce qu'il est capable
vraiment d'assurer cette affaire je peux
pas le juger et le rôle des autorités
burkinabè du président actuel roch marc
christian kaboré c'est ils ont eu le
courage instruit passer des gens qui ont
été intimidés qu'ils ont toujours un
timide et donc ils ont réussi à
instruire une affaire à l'opposé il
extradition bel exemple nationale comme
je vous dis on est on est dans un
dispositif où la france la côte d'ivoire
sont quand même des alliés puissants qui
empêche le burkina d'aller jusqu'au bout
de son mais ils ont fait la demande on
attend l'extradition on sait que les
hits les autorités ivoiriennes ne feront
pas pourquoi la france at-elle aidé a
expliqué blaise compaore c'est une bonne
question que vous français devrait poser
à vos propres consignes comment vous
jugez l'attitude de la france
aujourd'hui est clairement hypocrite
comme à l'époque coloniale c'est la
france qui a exfiltré blaise compaore
donc je crois que sur cette question là
comme les déclassification que nous
avons obtenus ça fait des années que
nous demandons la déclassification des
documents effectivement saluant le fait
que le président macron a osé faire ce
que ni mitterrand ni hollande ni sarkozy
ont voulu faire nous ont libérés des
documents nous avons vu les documents
nous savons qu'il ya d'autres documents
beaucoup plus important qui aurait dû
être libérée hélas nous ne les avons pas
en notre possession on a obtenu le
dernier lot juste à la fermeture après
l'instruction par toutes sortes de
retard imputable davantage à la france
et je sais qu'ils devraient avoir un
quatrième lot après le troisième lot
mais hélas qui ne viendra pas donc si on
veut vraiment tourner les pages c'est
d'ailleurs même quand vous regardez ces
deux interpellé là dessus les autorités
françaises où il joue au niveau est
évidemment puisque de toutes les façons
c'est elle qui ont eu la bonté de zuku
délier les secret est révélé quand vous
regardez le type de surveillance auquel
sont soumis nos chefs d'état comment
sont soumis les gens de la société
civile à l'époque un yaya même pas de
conflit voyez qu'il ya une souffrance
d'intelligence extraordinaire sur tous
nos agissements est bon ce n'est pas le
problème de la france c'est le propre
des puissants de pouvoir le faire mais
c'est bien la preuve que à ce moment il
ya d'autres documents beaucoup plus
compromettants qui ne sont plus là il y
a le fait que des personnages importants
comme guy penne ont disparu mais à
d'autres gens qui sont encore là et dans
la mémoire n'est pas nécessairement
fuligineuses par exemple roland dumas
qui pourrait peut-être raconter des
choses jack lang qui pourrait nous dire
des choses sur ce qu'était ce régime
mitterrand et les connivences de
l'époque car c'est des gens qui avaient
une intelligence de ce qui se passait il
ya d'autres protagonistes que je ne
nommerai pas qu'ils se font partie de
l'instruction et qu'on aimerait bien
aussi entendre pourquoi ce combat que
vous menez contre l'impunité finalement
ils s'invitent ici au contre sommet
afrique france et bien moi j'ai été
invité à ce contre sommet parce
qu'effectivement beaucoup de deux
patriotes français des gens qui sont
progressistes considère que ce sommet
que nous nous appelons toujours
françafrique et non pas afrique-france
moi je suis allé c'était le cas alors
françois hollande oui je sais c'est
justement de dénomination mais les
choses sont encore les choses sont têtus
c'est un sommet france afrique on
discute de l'afrique en france avec des
jeunes africains et triés sur le volet
qui incarne un peu le dynamisme de la
société africaine en pleine
mondialisation donc on a quelques sujets
bombe deschamps dans le design des gens
dans le milieu des affaires des gens
dans la culture et les sports mais les
grands enjeux la condition féminine
l'enjeu de nos ressources la question de
la sécurité les vrais enjeux ne sont pas
posé la question de la souveraineté ne
sont pas posées mais c'est de bonne
guerre même si nous on trouve une forme
de paternalisme à vouloir coopté une
portion de notre société civile pour
remaquiller la politique française c'est
assez surprenant jamais on imaginerait
des français invités dans un pays
africain pour faire la même chose ou
bien la grande bretagne invité nos
sociétés civiles pour revoir
la politique étrangère de la grande
bretagne mais ça fait partie de je crois
la façon par laquelle le paternalisme
mais quelle est votre appréciation
réelle de ce nouveau format le nouveau
sommet afrique france sans les chefs
d'état est une première c'est très
rafraîchissant et très singulier de voir
un chef d'état qui sont un homme et qui
propose d'autres façons de faim dont
comme on dit en anglais qui bypass les
ses collègues bilatéraux et qui va
s'adresser à certains pans trier de la
société civile mais nos classes
laborieuses ne sont pas consultés le
vrai masse qui sont exposés au problème
du sous développement ne sont pas
consultés ce qui lutte pour la
souveraineté ne sont pas consultés et
des gens comme nous ne serons jamais
invités c'est bien la preuve que les
dires des gens comme vous des collectifs
panafricanisme panafricain authentiques
qu'ils savent pertinemment que les
sujets qui fâchent mais qui permettrait
à la france des lumières d'être
véritablement un acteur du changement
des politiques ça ce serait que la chose
qu'il faudrait poser et un jour tôt ou
tard d'abord les premières conditions
c'est qu'on est moins deux leaders
comprend d'or parce qu'effectivement eux
mêmes doivent être excédé d'avoir des
leaders chefs d'état plus ou moins
larbins qui écoutent leurs injonctions
donc à un moment ils se disent allons
parler à d'autres gens et là je les
comprends mais les alter ego d'un sujet
comme cela c'est l'union africaine c'est
vraiment au niveau bilatéral que les
gens en exercice qui sont dans un
processus de décision discutante
bilatéraux les gens de la société civile
française peuvent interpeller leurs
pairs des sociétés civiles africaines
aient eu à voir entre eux des
discussions sur comment les grandes
tractations bilatéral devrait se faire
et c'est un peu ses modes qu'il nous
reste à lui peut-être à votre avis
délocaliser ce sommet en afrique non je
pense que ce sont justement ces exercice
laborieux de vouloir maquiller les vrais
enjeux les firmes multinationales
françaises elles fonctionnent elles
fonctionnent dans une matrice d'affaires
qui est déjà convenu le système des
firmes chinoises fonctionne dans leurs
trucs qui vont tous utiliser des sommet
chine-afrique ou françafrique on va même
avoir un sommet russie afrique et c'est
donc tout cela fait partie d'une forme
de diplomatie commerciale déjà avéré
qu'ils font leurs preuves et chacun a
ses styles pour nous en tout cas pas
l'africain la chose se passe ailleurs
les vrais enjeux sont ailleurs et ne
sont pas discutés dans des capitales ou
dans des villes secondaires
où on voudrait remodelé revampé et
encore ça faisait ça touche parce qu'on
coptes certains de nos intelligences ya
qui sont des gens sont toutes bien
intentionnés dans ces processus ont les
autres dans une matrice dont ils ne
contrôlent pas les aboutissants et c'est
déjà incluse et intelligents ils sont
pas instrumentalisés
mais ils ont la conviction eux mêmes
deux des acteurs du champ et sur les
initiatives
qu'il a prises depuis le début de son
mandat à savoir de consulter des
panafricanistes des philosophes
et finalement ça aboutit à des rapports
achille mbembe ici lui a remis son
rapport il ya quelques jours avec des
recommandations sur ces méthodes là
qu'est ce que vous en pensez j'espère
que d'autres rapports seront ouverts je
pense que achille lui-même disait que ce
processus sera sur plus long terme et
qui sont à plusieurs étapes et j'ose
espérer que des rapports moins
complaisant et des choses qui devraient
dit vont permettre à la france des
lumières liberté égalité fraternité
d'être vraiment cela dans leurs
relations et comment comment finir avec
les mots de la françafrique que vous
dénoncez écoutez moi en tout cas pour ce
qui me concerne une victoire par exemple
dans ce dossier saqqara serait
effectivement une page tournée ou sur la
france assume comme les autres assument
leurs responsabilités on peut tourner
les pages simples comme dans la lutte
contre l'apartheid à un moment il ya des
systèmes qui tombe et on assume et là on
va de façon épanouie ou alors on
continue de camoufler les choses
regarder leurs sentiments qui est
toujours là dans la question algérienne
regardez la situation qui a dans les
programmes du cameroun ou à madagascar
dont il ya des relents et la question
n'est pas de repentance et de bâtir de
nouveaux ponts bâtir une nouvelle
relation certes décomplexée mais franche
basé sur des rapports qui sont des vrais
partenariats ou nos peuples ne se
sentent pas laissés pour compte ou nos
peuples vraiment profiter et ça ça veut
dire où vont les ressources qu'ils
partagent véritablement les derniers
publics est ce que ces enrichissements
illicites vont continuer ce que les
formes de corruption continue et c'est
lorsqu'on aura dépassé ces choses là et
qu'on sera dans ce type de relation oui
il y aura une coopération authentique
aujourd'hui le public
au développement de la france comme la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et d eux
n'arrivent pas à 0 25% depuis 1969 on
nous promet 0,7 pour cent même l'argent
des immigrés et beaucoup supérieure à
cette coopération donc c'est juste pour
vous dire à la fois la réalité du monde
dans lequel on vit une polarisation qui
continue de creuser l'écart en ce qu'ils
possèdent et ceux qui ne possèdent pas
donc je ne m'attends pas qu'un régime de
centre-droit face et grands changements
lorsque même les socialistes français
n'ont pas réussi de faire ces grands
changements mais j'espère que les
générations des jeunes africains
africaine les jeunes français vont aller
vers ses rêves que nous avons de
relation plus saine plus égalitaire et
est contraire au haut disons à l'esprit
revanchard qui s'impose à cause de
l'impérialisme donc sortir de
l'impérialisme qui est le mot qu'on
n'entend pas beaucoup mais qui est la
relation dont il faut justement réussir
à tourner la page aziz selbonne fall
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien dans
l'afrique honnête mais aussi est
retrouvée après connecte sur nos réseaux
sociaux et en replay sur notre site rt
france point tv à très bientôt sur rt
france